so knowing that we're dumber and we
decide worse than men should we have an
equal vote as men oh man
I guess we do yeah because there's also
a funny man
good morning we're in a toxic
relationship you know but yeah yeah okay
okay so women are a nut taxpayer loss
meaning we spend more money than we make
okay okay so on top of that on top of
that we're easy to manipulate with
propaganda so they'll show us a video of
a 12 year old chick that can't get an
abortion and we just run to the polls
we're like oh my God I need to go vote
for this 12 year old and and then on top
of that we make up more of the
population and we don't do any of the
hard jobs so building the buildings the
roads all that we don't really do it